uh and i you know i miss sports and i
miss so i'm trying to find a way to do
that you know it's hard like with
you know
like with our industry it's like you're
not really allowed to do anything that i
really love doing you know when you're
like on a series like
i can't just like those kind of go climb
something you know
wait a minute you can't do that stuff
but you could throw your body around in
a
in a wrestling ring and just destroy
yourself but you can't do that you you
destroy yourself on
not
our
time
time
isn't that what happens that's exactly
what happens they're paying you a lot of
money they want you to be you know be
alive they want you to
be on set so they could destroy you do
you do a lot of your own [ __ ] like on
the heels by the way guys is on stars
it's uh it's awesome it's like amateur
wrestling right
yeah yeah it's about what's that i mean
it's yeah it's like it's about pro
wrestling in small town georgia and
um you know these guys with with big
dreams i want to make another small town
and um you know i've never i i wouldn't
say that traditionally i was like
brought up on it or something that i was
like crazy about even though i did watch
it as a kid but um
that whole way of life is just so
fascinating to me um just what these
guys put their bodies and minds through
for like
for their dreams is really inspiring i
mean these guys they use and abuse their
bodies on a regular basis they got no
help and they're just driving from town
to town just to you know it's it's their
version of the of the nhl right yeah or
the nfl or whatever so um
i became an actor to be able to tell
stories about things that even i don't
know about so that was that was really
exciting yeah
but yeah like
you know
it's so funny i love when i hear actors
go like oh yeah like i do all my own
stones i'm like you're so full of [ __ ]
man there's one person in the world that
does all his own stunts says tom cruise
but tom tom is a is a certified stunt
man and you know like when you get to
that level i think you can
you can
demand certain things you know like but
for me
like i will happily do stunts but it's
it's just
you know um you're not an idiot you know
when to walk away
yeah and also not to mention like you
know this like stuntman makes an
adjustment on a son so it's like when
you don't you know like you want to look
out for your your fellow stuntman too so
but like steven and i talked about this
and like
you can't really fake it yeah when
you're when you're doing a show like
fuels like you can't you can't just like
fake wrestling in the rings like most of
that stuff we learned to do and i would
say 90 of it we did do but there's
certain things that you know we have
incredible sun guys do like fall off of
the top of the cage like they're not
letting us do that there's just no way
and
it'd be stupid of me to do that because
we don't need to it's probably hard to
stop a male though
stephen stephen likes to do he loves
wrestling more than anybody and i i know
that he likes to do his own stuff and he
gets injured and things like that but he
goes the extra mile doesn't he
for sure and that's one thing i love
about him too like
um i didn't know what to expect when we
first met each other and you know for me
i've always gone into like stuff just
with the mindset of
um look we don't have to be best friends
but let's just show up and put give 110
to everything we do and remember how
grateful we are and stephen was that and
more like he's a brother to me and i
love him and he cared so much about this
um you know that he's he's got such a
soft spot for wrestling and he's such a
massive fan of it so he was such an
asset to me and we really pushed each
other i think to just get the best
performance as possible i mean
the last episode of heels i swear to god
the crew thought we killed each other
because
we
we went all out and um and i'm so
grateful to have like just like you know
a partner who would do that with me do
you like that do you like that intensity
where you're like i don't is it a
feeling of i don't know if he's really
serious right now but i'm gonna like
you're keeping up almost like are we
fighting right now is he going he's
doing a little more than i thought he
was going to do that we talked about
yeah i love that like we like we did a
take we did a take and i remember we
looked we saw it back and we were like
nah
like this isn't working and we're like
all right let's do one let's go all out
on one this is going to really hurt and
it's going to suck but let's do it like
100 let's go and that was i mean that's
fun as hell and you feel like you just
like went
went to war together or something you
know like you're just like wow we we
really we really did that